son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna seguimos comentándoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
después de un fin de semana de protestas
en China contra su política de cero Coby
del país vivió una jornada de calma bajo
un intenso control policial la Casa
Blanca seguro que el presidente Joe
biden monitorea de cerca las
manifestaciones al tiempo que Naciones
Unidas pidió respetar la protesta
pacífica
Brandon declarado supremacista y autor
confeso del tiroteo que tuvo lugar en
mayo pasado en la ciudad estadounidense
de Búfalo Se declaró culpable de
asesinato en primer grado y de otros
cargos estatales por lo que podría
enfrentar cadena perpetua
la crisis climática deja sentir su
efecto en el archipiélago de las
maldivas donde se empieza a hablar de
una posible inundación de cerca del 20%
del territorio si la temperatura global
aumenta no obstante al menos el 71% de
la población depende del océano como
principal fuente de ingresos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
vamos inicio en China porque Beijing y
otras ciudades se encuentran bajo fuerte
custodia policial tras las protestas del
fin de semana Las mayores registradas en
años en esta ocasión para condenar la
política de cero covid del gobierno las
multitudinarias movilizaciones se
produjeron en ciudades como Beijing o
Shangai luego de que murieran 10
personas en un incendio del que
presuntamente no pudieron escapar debido
al confinamiento obligatorio los
ciudadanos exigen el fin de las
restricciones que empezaron hace
alrededor de tres años
estas calles ahora Aparentemente
tranquilas fueron el escenario de un fin
de semana lleno de protestas poco
comunes contra el gobierno chino y su
política de Cero covid en unas jornadas
inéditas de desobediencia civil desde
que el presidente chillin asumió el
poder hace más de una década La chispa
que encendió la llama fue el incendio en
el edificio de urún capital de donde
según los ciudadanos a las operaciones
de rescate se complicaron por las
restricciones contra el covid versión
que las autoridades niegan las protestas
se extendieron rápidamente por
diferentes puntos del país como Shangai
uhana
como todo el mundo sabe en los últimos
años se ha bloqueado nuestra libertad de
expresión y las distintas formas de
expresarnos No pensé en que llegaría el
día en el que saldríamos a la calle para
expresar nuestras demandas
Y es que los chinos llevan tres años
lidiando con las estrictas políticas
Ahora aunque no hay confinamientos a
nivel nacional las autoridades locales
deben imponer estrictos cierres se
detectan positivos en Kobe 19 pero a
pesar de las críticas nacionales e
internacionales el gobierno chino
sostuvo que las protestas Fueron
fomentadas por occidente
creemos que con el liderazgo del partido
comunista chino y el apoyo del pueblo
chino nuestra lucha contra el Kobe 19
tendrá éxito
desde el inicio de las protestas se
registraron imágenes de la represión de
la policía china con un número
indeterminado de detenidos entre ellos
el periodista de la cadena bbc Lawrence
detenido durante varias horas en
Shanghai y supuestamente agredido por la
policía antes de liberarlo una situación
que ha generado preocupación entre la
comunidad internacional con protestas de
solidaridad en países como Reino Unido o
Japón y que ha hecho que los mercados
mundiales se desplomen este raro gesto
de desobediencia por parte del pueblo
chino
tras el silencio del fin de semana La
Casa Blanca respondió a las
manifestaciones que están sacudiendo a
las ciudades de China desde Washington
pidieron que se respete el derecho de
los ciudadanos a protestar de manera
pacífica al tiempo que se mostraron
críticos con la política de cero covid
que conlleva a rigurosos cuarentenas
aislamientos y restricciones que se
mantienen activas desde hace cerca de
tres años
Estamos observando a China muy de cerca
como esperábamos hacerlo y ahora
nosotros continuamos apoyando el derecho
a la protesta pacífica Tendremos que
seguir vigilándolo muy de cerca y ver
Hacia dónde se dirige esto este lunes el
joven acusado de haber matado 10
afroamericanos en un supermercado de la
Ciudad de Búfalo en el estado de Nueva
York Se declaró culpable de asesinatos
racistas y actos de terrorismo su juicio
está previsto para febrero y se enfrenta
la cadena perpetua y hasta la pena de
muerte Gabriel corson tiene los detalles
este lunes el joven acusado de haber
llevado a cabo la matanza en un
supermercado de la Ciudad de Búfalo se
ha declarado culpable el 14 de mayo
asesinó a 10 personas afroe
estadounidenses un acto calificado de
racista y terrorista
nuestro cliente se ha declarado culpable
de todos los cargos Sabiendo
perfectamente que pasará el resto de su
vida en prisión
las autoridades dicen que el autor
confesó de 19 años buscaba
específicamente matar a personas afroe
estadounidenses cuando abrió Fuego en la
tienda según Los investigadores el
atacante público en internet antes del
tiroteo un discurso racista en el que se
declaraba Suprema si está blanco y
prometía matar a afroamericanos
investigó y se dirigió específicamente a
la tienda Tops de la avenida Jefferson
por su ubicación incluso llegó a ser una
búsqueda de Google del código postal del
estado de Nueva York que la mayor
concentración de afroamericanos
este masacre tuvo lugar solo 10 días
después de otra matanza perpetrada por
un joven de 18 años que mató a 19 niños
y dos profesores en una escuela de
uvaldi en Texas desde entonces han
aumentado el número de tiroteos masivos
alimentando la frustración de los
estadounidenses frente a la falta de
solución respecto a la multiplicación de
matanzas el presidente demócrata
dubaidane todavía no ha conseguido
impulsar en el congreso la prohibición
de los fusiles de asalto debido a la
oposición republicana
Hablamos ahora de la guerra en Ucrania
las autoridades de ese país han estado
han restablecido el suministro
energético en gran parte de la nación
tras los ataques rusos de esta del fin
de semana en regiones como gerson los
ciudadanos vuelven a tener acceso al gas
y la electricidad en medio de la
devastación causada por los bombardeos y
las advertencias de que los ataques
podrían repetirse Alba Santana nos
cuenta más
tras día sin gas ni electricidad el
ludmila antonenco y su hijo Alexander
vuelven a tener acceso a estos servicios
en su casa de gerson tenemos gas tenemos
electricidad Ojalá tuviéramos agua
también para usar el baño adecuadamente
el 24 de noviembre una bomba
supuestamente rusa cayó sobre su casa
las ventanas saltaron por los aires y
una de las paredes colapsó ahora a pesar
de que la casa está en ruinas madre e
hijo siguen aquí porque no tienen otro
sitio donde ir
la ventana se llenó de luz todo se
iluminó luego hubo muchas explosiones
estábamos muy asustados Me alegro de que
Alexander siga aquí si hubiera caído
Entre 10 y 30 centímetros más hacia aquí
yo no estaría aquí pero tengo 82 años no
es para tanto
otros no tuvieron tanta suerte como
Lilia krishenko que perdió a sus dos
padres en ese mismo ataque
había mucho polvo no podía ver nada mi
hijo y yo nos escondimos en el baño hoy
a mi padre gritar diciéndome que llamara
una ambulancia porque mi madre estaba
herida pero no había conexión
a pesar de que el gas y la electricidad
en los dos servicios más importantes de
cara al infierno se han restablecido los
ciudadanos de gerson no tienen acceso al
agua ni a otras redes como la de la
televisión además el presidente bolo de
imercelenski ha advertido a los
ucranianos que todavía no están a salvo
sabemos que los terroristas están
planeando nuevos ataques lo sabemos con
certeza y mientras tengan misiles
desafortunadamente no se calmarán
una situación complicada de cara al
invierno cada vez más cerca y para el
que los ucranianos sumidos en la guerra
no están preparados
Este martes sí en organizaciones
sociales de América Latina se reúnen en
Bogotá para participar en la conferencia
Regional de derechos humanos de 2022
para analizar esta situación de Derechos
Humanos en Latinoamérica conectamos con
Marcia águiluz ella es directora legal
para América Latina de la organización
women's link World White bienvenida a
France 24 Cuál es la situación de
Derechos Humanos en nuestra región
actualmente En cuáles materias se puede
hablar de mejorías y En cuales de
retroceso
Sí muy buenas noches efectivamente
tenemos una región bastante compleja en
términos de mejorías realmente
vemos con esperanza digamos en algunos
países gobiernos que al menos en el
discurso están planteando un discurso de
combatir la desigualdad y ahí podemos
señalar acá por ejemplo en Colombia
podemos señalar el caso también de chile
sin embargo lo que más nos preocupa las
organizaciones que estamos acá reunidas
son precisamente los retrocesos verdad
retrocesos en términos de la
militarización y muchos de los países
por ejemplo en el caso de México en el
caso del Salvador países que han
restringido los espacios de
participación política por supuesto el
caso de Nicaragua el caso de Venezuela
que son prácticamente gobiernos
completamente cerrados y como en
términos estructurales tenemos una
desigualdad que caracteriza toda la
región Y cómo esa desigualdad está
afectando a históricamente discriminados
Como por ejemplo las mujeres los pueblos
indígenas la población afrodescendiente
encontramos además otra problemática muy
seria que es el fenómeno de las
migraciones verdad como tenemos
migraciones masivas la mayoría hacia el
norte Pero algunas por ejemplo en
Centroamérica observamos migraciones lo
que llamamos hacia el sur verdad
personas de Nicaragua personas del
Salvador de Honduras migrando hacia
Costa Rica y hacia Panamá Entonces es un
fenómeno que nos preocupa muchísimo y
por otra parte el crimen organizado que
es un fenómeno regional Que
prácticamente afecta a toda la región
entonces
realmente eso encontramos algunos países
en los que en el discurso se pretende
avanzar por ejemplo en términos de
violencia de género en términos de
garantías de personas LG de lgbtiq más
pero en realidad hay problemas
estructurales que todavía no se están
abordando y que generan estos problemas
que estamos que estoy señalando en
algunas naciones ya usted lo estaba
mencionando derechos humanos son
violados por los gobiernos y por las
autoridades responsables de defenderlos
quién puede entonces ser garante en
estos territorios
Bueno la verdad es que la garantía
siempre la tienen los estados y esa es
una preocupación existen sistemas
internacionales de protección por
ejemplo el sistema interamericano o el
sistema de Naciones Unidas pero
realmente
pues son sistemas que son débiles porque
tienen que respetar la soberanía de los
estados y aunque son sistemas que emanan
recomendaciones que en muchos casos son
vinculantes nuevamente se regresa al
estado y si los estados los gobiernos no
responden pues simplemente estas
recomendaciones se quedan en el papel
corresponden todo caso pues en primer
lugar a los Estados garantizar los
Derechos Humanos pero también a la
comunidad internacional
no solamente a través del uso por
ejemplo el sistema interamericano de
protección de Derechos Humanos sino a
los Estados en los diálogos bilaterales
que tienen entre ellos poner los temas
de Derechos Humanos en la agenda Brian
agendas bilaterales en términos
económicos pero en términos de Derechos
Humanos muchos se deja de lado Entonces
sí hay una responsabilidad primaria que
no podemos evadir y son los gobiernos
pero la comunidad internacional los
organismos internacionales También
tienen una responsabilidad Marcia Pues a
usted muchas gracias por su análisis y
por compartirlo con nosotros en francés
24 gracias a ustedes ahora vamos hasta
el archipiélago de las maldivas porque
en este país formado por más de mil
Islas se empieza a hablar de una posible
inundación de cerca del 20% del
territorio si la temperatura global
aumenta por lo menos el 71% de la
población depende del océano como
principal fuente de ingresos pero su
posición geográfica pone a la nación en
una situación complicada sino aumentan
los esfuerzos globales por reducir el
calentamiento global Juan Pablo lukumi
tiene los detalles
un aumento de 2 grados en la temperatura
global sería una sentencia de muerte
para las maldivas
posicionaba tan solo 1,5 metros sobre el
nivel del mar las maldivas es un país
formado por casi 1200 islas repartidas
en 90.000 kilómetros de océano por su
posición geográfica y baja altitud una
subida del nivel del mar podría poner a
diferentes partes del país bajo el agua
los científicos de nequion Mission de
Reino Unido están explorando partes del
océano que nadie había visto antes
tienen como objetivo recopilar los datos
sobre la vida Marina desde la superficie
hasta los 1000 metros y determinar la
salud del océano
maldivas es un país que tiene un 99% de
océanos también está en la primera línea
de la crisis climática los habitantes de
las maldivas han hecho muy poco para
provocar la crisis climática pero el
nivel del océano está subiendo y va a
afectar primero a los lugares como este
todo mientras las principales potencias
buscan limitar el calentamiento global a
1,5 grados centígrados algo que expertos
prevén que no se logrará para final de
siglo si no se ajustan las políticas de
los principales emisores de carbono del
mundo
el problema no es la falta de tecnología
el problema no es la financiación el
problema Es la falta de voluntad
política y por eso creo que necesitamos
que los líderes políticos tomen una
decisión Audaz para abordar este
problema
se espera que con la misión británica se
proteja por lo menos el 20% del
territorio oceánico en un país donde más
del 70% depende del agua que lo rodea
para gestionar sus ingresos llegamos
hacia el final de esta misión de directo
América a ustedes Les agradecemos su
sintonía y los invitamos a continuar con
nosotros que ya llegamos al venormal con
toda la información del continente
africano en África 7 días feliz noche
para todos
[Música]